Iran's president says his country will
remain committed to its nuclear deal
with the West even if the u.s. pulls out
the Financial Times reports Hassan
rouhani said yesterday Iran's leaders
already considered the u.s. no longer a
party to the deal Great Britain is one
of the other nations involved tonight my
colleague Bret Baier talks with a
British ambassador to the u.s. about
Iran and other critical issues mr.
Basner thanks for the time thank you for
inviting me I wanted to go over a couple
of items that obviously are very
important between the US and Great
Britain one is is Iran and the constant
threat from Iran but also what is going
on with the Iran nuclear deal and what's
the view in the UK about things well
first thing to say is that we agreed
with this administration agree with the
president that what Iran is doing in the
region whether in Syria in Lebanon in
Iraq in Yemen is unacceptable we need to
work together to push back on Iranian
influence and activities in the region
we also agree with the administration in
terms of concerns about Iran's ballistic
missile development and we are talking
now about ways of addressing that we
think the jcpoa the Iran nuclear deal is
not a perfect deal but it's a good deal
and it helps it's you know it's good for
European international security but we
hear what the president says about it we
understand that he has some concerns
about it so we're also working with the
administration to see if we can find a
way forward that preserves the deal
he obviously laid down the gauntlet this
last time saying it's the last time he's
going to renew it if it's not changed it
leaves the ball in Congress's court and
also the international community how
likely is that going to happen I think
the next waiver comes up in May
there was a meeting only last week
senior officials to address the issues
that the concern the president so we
will be working to try and get a way
forward that all of us can sign up to
but we know that that in Congress they
will have a role and a view on this as
well so we talked a lot of them to both
sides of our to Democrats and
Republicans about a way forward what
about the relationship between the UK
and the US this president obviously has
said and we did some things that have
gotten raised a lot of eyebrows and in
your country he said recently the reason
I canceled my trip to London is that I'm
not a big fan of the Obama
administration having sold perhaps the
best located finest embassy in London
for peanuts only to build a new one in
an off location for a one point two
billion dollars bad deal wanted me to
cut ribbon no and then he says to the
prime minister Theresa May don't focus
on me focus on the destructive radical
Islamic terrorism that's taking place
within the UK we're doing just fine that
was back in November
obviously there's tension the London
Mayor others how do you characterize the
relationship it's a good strong
relationship and they meet and talk a
lot we have the privilege of the prime
minister being the first visitor to see
the president since then I think we've
met probably half a dozen times at
international meetings they talk on the
telephone every few weeks they met in
Davos only a week ago truly and really
successful meeting serration ship is
very good at that level we all know that
of course
Brett it's a hugely strong relationship
in lots of other areas intelligence
security defence and the trade
relationship 200 billion dollars worth
of trade both ways and with bricks it
and the potential for doing a free trade
agreement between the UK and the US you
know future is going to be even bigger
so you're saying despite the occasional
dust-up that maybe a little iceberg that
there's a lot more under the water in
this iceberg as far as the relationship
exactly I mean I've been 40 years in the
Foreign Service
I've seen a number of presidents and
prime ministers there is never I think
being a moment when the richer ship
hasn't been really deep and strong but
also never a moment where there hasn't
been one or two issues on which we
disagree two more things that you
mentioned terrorism dealing with
terrorist attacks five attacks in 2017
in the UK mi5 saying they're running
approximately 500 operations looking at
3,000 subjects of interest radical Islam
is still a major concern for the UK as
it is for the u.s. mi5 do an
extraordinary job in combating radical
Islamic terrorism in pre-empting
terrorist crimes before they happen but
the threat is ever-present is going to
be there for a generation and we will be
intensify efforts tackle it and working
with our partners in beauty of course
here in Washington to take this on
finally you mentioned brexit and there
is still a lot of angst about how this
is all gonna work I know in the UK
obviously figuring it out but in the
world economy and how it's going to
affect things where do you put it now
and and the prospects of a brexit the
next task is to agree transitional
arrangements that will give certainty
and continuity not just a British but
two international businesses present in
the UK and beyond that we need to work
out a future trading relationship with
the EU
I'm confident we will achieve all of
that but also confident we have this
great opportunity then to forge much
stronger trade relationships with the
rest of the world free trade agreements
starting with here in the US and you
sense that the economy is on the upswing
Dubai is is doing fine I have to say I'm
a bit envious of quite how strongly the
US economy has performed over the last
year or two but we are growing solidly
and steadily mr. ambassador we
appreciate the time thank you very much
for giving the opportunity